the gradient is just a measure of how
stable line is right gradient one would
look like that gradient two would look
like that this gradient is so in between
that would be an angle a gradient is
just a number
gradient not an angle agree it tells you
anything I'll come back to when I come
to a snow peas paper I'll show you what
I mean
exactly right I'm going to write down
all of them three to seven okay so let
me just check with you your what your
piece of paper sells this is what my
piece of paper says I hope that looks
pretty good
okay now just to kiss pumpkin I've got
the question before Radian right what
does that even mean this is not an angle
on an angle it's a measure of the
steepness of the line so for instance
I'm sure think I even have a queue here
we go if this was our line of best fit
okay
if for example I measured this angle
here I'm just going to make a guess I
think it looks something like 45 degrees
well as the men's exactly what it
started but anyway it's not my point
there's a gradient of this line M would
be 1 it means when you ride one unit you
run one year that's a great integer
there but rise over run so the grade is
just this number it's not the angle I
don't really have to worry about the
angle at all for what I'm doing right
now okay so what did we just find this
1.37 etcetera number
it's the gradient of this line for our
data not look this render in defense
okay come back to the FOB reduction on
the fluoridation we've just worked out
gradient so now we're up to working out
y-intercepts okay
so at this point it says why
bah that's the made of wine takeaway and
then you can see what's going on right
so I'm going to go to my calculator now
I've still got my gradient on that I'm
going to clear that out and now I'm
going to work out how to get this
y-intercept
okay the first thing I need is y bar so
shift 1 where's it going to be do you
see a wine bar there looks like it's not
the fun there's why thought I'm going to
take away and then in brackets this is
gradient right now I actually you guys
know that we can actually calculate the
gradient and then we can store it maybe
I might do that just quickly in case you
can't remember so once I work out let's
go back it's our time it wasn't one
divided by legend but this is exams yeah
that point you can't type in the exact
you were only going to get ten decimal
places my exact has like like hundred
the desolation conservation example okay
I'm going to store the stove on I'm just
going by the way
just have a look at your calculator this
is a gradient right you can call it
anything you like but what would make
sense as a letter to choose and if
you've got an M you then free so I'm
going to go shift store and I'm going to
put it down okay do you see where it is
it's element to go
[Music]
okay so now I'm going to do my
y-intercept right what am i doing take
away shift shift
yeah store and then pick a letter
everything here XY am I picked them so I
press this button okay - John - let's
try this this is me working out the
y-intercept now do you see how that
represents us almost $40 shade and what
they're asking me to do is y bar there's
the gradient right there and there's X
bar did I do it right time yeah that's
it right yeah yeah good number got it so
now I'm going to go back to my table and
I'm going to write crap - it's not let
me use the hammer I alpha alpha press
alpha to get to alphabet try that the
the Eliana if you are pressing the
import button do not change the value
very nice reckon the M should still be
what it was intended okay so let's look
at my piece of paper done so this is
what make this paper says write this was
M and this would be so what is the
equation the equation will be y equals
and I'm going to approximate this point
so I'm probably going to write one point
three eight X minus twenty nine point
four eight what do you think
with where do we scroll there's nothing
else on the outside head to my head okay
so this one in page six okay now is this
what we expected on that one point three
eight that represents the gradient of
the line I want you to look on your
screen on your laptop screen look at
where the line would go through is a
gradient 1.38
look about right positive right
now what if this would this mean -
tweaking I put for a this is the
y-intercept that's where our line of
business is going to cut the y-axis
right so watch this I got my IQ and I'm
going to put in this equation y equals
what did I say one point three eight X
and then I'm going to say minus twenty
nine point all right not bad and if I
remember that one that I did by hand
remember the one I did my hand I'll show
you the one I did my head this is the
one that I did by here and you can see I
tried to I put a whole bunch of stuff on
there which is distracting let me get
rid of that so when I did that by hand I
said yeah I want roughly the same above
and below and also you notice I put that
middle one I put bang-on I was just
estimating right now looking at what the
calculator has actually told us they've
got something slightly different now
you'll see there's actually three below
three data points below the line of best
fit and two above can you explain why
there is actually there isn't one right
of line what do I think the top one is
much further above right in fact if you
even go back to when I drew on top of
this let's put all that stuff back you
can see how much larger this one is
right so to calculate it it wanted to
make this a bit smaller and it didn't
mind making these ones a bit larger it's
still a better fit in a more technical
accurate sense that okay